hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game that was played in the
speed chess championship anchez calm
Hikaru Nakamura versus yung shue stuff
Duda and as we were covering the
Grantchester yesterday I've been
receiving a lot of messages you know
something like dude check out this game
have you seen the game Nakamura versus
Duda and there were a lot of these
messages obviously the game was really
interesting so today when I finally saw
the game I understood why all the
messages and if we're wondering about
the the title of the video what's a bar
in the library mortal we're gonna
discuss that after we check out the game
so without further ado Nakamura wit the
white pieces opens with E 4 with E 5 by
do dot Knight to f3 sorry about that
and Knight to f6 we have the petrol of
Defense by Judah Knight captures on d5
d6 and now while mostly you'll see night
to have 3 here other retreats are also
possible night the c-4 is possible night
the d3 is possible Alexander a moto say
which one some a very important games
with Knight captures on f7 those were
blitz game is but still a very
interesting idea but here Nakamura goes
for night to d3 same as a cross and
tried again score wanna for example in
Game six of the 2018 World Chess
Championship match Knight captures on e4
Quinta ytube attacking the knight and
Queen to e7 defending Knight to f4 and
not Knight to c6 and here we reach the
exact same position of the game 6 of the
World Chess Championship match between
calls and Cortana where Carlson
continued with nice the d5 but here we
have c3 preparing d4 we have Knight back
to f6 now offering a queen trade and
just d4 by nakamura here both players
have wanted the other guy to capture the
Queen because well if you capture the
Queen then you just help the other guy
develop his pieces so the bishop to f5
here there are non moves or Queen
captures on e2 and the g5 but Bishop to
f5 the move
Duda plate is a new move in the position
so already as of move 8 we have a
completely new game
we've been stripped III by Nakamura
preparing to develop the night now in
Castle queenside so the Queen trade is
no longer on the table with d5 and now
comes night study to preparing the
Castle queenside here do that Castle
queenside and Nakamura follows by also
castling queenside and it's always
dangerous to catch the Queen set for
example when you have a light square
Bishop slicing through this diagonal now
it'd be it'd be perfectly cool if this
Bishop wasn't d3 then it's it's not a
problem but with this Queen on e2 and
Bishop on f1 setup it could be somewhat
problematic and here do that place the
move from the thumbnail Queen to a3 so
it's not a forcing move or anything
since you're not forced to capture the
Queen and allow Bishop captures an a3
there's a beautiful double Bishop mate
but it does create problems for you how
do you continue developing for example
if you continue 93 you block this
diagonal you have to allow Queen
captures on a - there is no way around
it and now if Knight f3 trying to make
some room for your King night Stewie for
again takes the D to square away from
the White King again you are threatening
Queen to a one mate so after Queen to c2
you have to try something but then
Knight a5 comes then the knight comes to
b3 and you can already see that a lot of
things went wrong here
so instead after Queen to a3 Nakamura of
course did not capture he went for Queen
to b5 instead now he wants to block the
the Bishop with Bishop to d3 we have
Queen captures and a2 by Judah ending
our Bishop to d3 and now okay if Queen
a1 check just came to see - and now the
rook from d1 also attacks the black
queen so Bishop captures on d3 Queen
captures on d3 and now Knight to a5
again with the idea of bringing this
Knight over to b3 so you could try
something like Queen to be one it is
definitely the way to go and after the
Queen moves you can start pushing the
black Queen away and continue playing
this game being down upon but we do have
to remember this is a blitz game and we
are only you know not over analyzing
with games we're just enjoying them
Queen to c2 by sorry King to
Nakamura trying to get the King away as
soon as possible get the rook in and
start marching the King to the Kings
side we have Queen a for check King back
to be one and now kinked a beard you
could start with rook d6 rookie six
right away but do the figures you know a
nice prophylactic King b8 is never a
waste of time
so Knights the f3 and now comes Rock the
d6 preparing rook to a6 or maybe in some
cases rook the b6 depending on what
white plays Nakamura goes Knight back to
d2 and here we have looked a six now
preparing to move the knight and bring
the Queen although all the way to the
White King and here Nakamura says okay
we're not having that I have nice
control of the be three squares so let's
just go Queen to c2 we're trading Queens
and you know we're just gonna continue
this game but Duda says no way man
there's something else I have planned
here so feel free to pause the video and
try to find this beautiful idea do that
played in this game in this position
well I'll give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on helping do that
create the library and bar immortal game
and for those who just want to enjoy the
show it's Quinta a 1 check that's that's
a beautiful move because of course white
has no other options than to capture the
Queen King capture sunny one and now
well not more of course resigned at
Quinta a1 check because he saw that
there there's nothing to be done here
but after King capture Sunday one nice
to me 3a discovered to check also it's
double check since the night also checks
the white teen you will have to go to be
one and then roped a one is mate so
really really impressive stuff taking
down Nakamura in 20 moves with not one
Queen sacrifice but to well Kate the
first one wasn't a real sacrifice but it
was a Queen sacrifice offer so that
still counts when you when you rate the
coolness of a chess game so really
really an awesome game I do hope you
enjoyed it and in the end Nakamura want
the match but dude I got this beautiful
victory it's a like love Paula games he
said that he would trade his dozen
victory
is over a refuge Medina for one game and
there's billion of one against him
because that game is the game everyone
is talking about so I don't know
Nakamura would trade all of his
victories for this one game there is a
the game ended with 15 and half to 11
and a half so quite a convincing victory
by Nakamura but this game will remain
and hopefully your friends and at the
bar in the library will also enjoy so
that's what I meant by the bar and
library mortal this will be the first
game in the bar in library mortal series
those will be games that you can easily
remember and easily show to your friends
at the bar and the library and impress
them and you know improve their day so
if you have a game like that or you know
of a game like that being played
regardless of who played it just send it
you know hashtag suggestion borrowing
library mortal we're gonna check it out
and hopefully the series picks up so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
you can check out the entire matches
that comes YouTube channel so if you're
if you want to enjoy the whole match as
well you can check that out I would like
to thank Chris Picard for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous video serum thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
Grantchester hopefully and getting some
hash tag bar and library immortal
suggestions and of course continue our
next big saga when we finish off
everything else that we are doing so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day